COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some fitness
professionals
with their Bigtable
index design.
Will we have the time to
get an extra workout in?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
From a performance perspective,
one of the most important
things to consider while
designing your Bigtable schema
is your index design,
which is something
that our friends at Urban
Fitness Forge, makers
of Fitness Tracker products,
ran into headlong recently.
UFF's usage pattern
for their data
dominantly queried lat-long
values to find specific sensors
within an area for analysis.
Or rather, given how
often they ran this query,
it was way too slow
for their needs.
Their initial schema
design used a row key
comprised of lat-long values.
And as it turned out,
this simple setup
was exactly the problem.
The reason for this is two
things working together.
Firstly, Bigtable doesn't
have explicit support
for secondary indexes.
So if you want to
find a group of people
with the same first
and last name,
then you can get a very
fast first name search,
but you have to do a
secondary search in a less
than performant fashion.
Secondly, entries in a tablet
are sorted lexicographically
by their index, meaning that
entries with similar keys
will be closer to each
other in the tablet space.
Now, since the dominant
part of UFF's key
was the latitude
value, other cities
which shared the same latitude
value were listed closely
in the table, meaning that their
secondary scan for a longitude
value was walking through
loads more data, and of course
was less performant as a result.
This highlights an
important aspect
of Bigtable schema design.
The wrong key design could spell
disaster for your performance.
For Urban Fitness Forge,
that meant creating an index
such that entries that are close
to each other in physical space
were sorted close to
each other in tablespace
to reduce scan size.
So instead of using a lat-long
value which produced a Raster
style order index
like this one, they
were able to use a space-filling
curve which organized indexes
in physical space like this.
The result is a modified
index for entries
which use a space-filling curve
integrated with a timestamp
value to create a single
integer-based index.
For Urban Fitness
Forge, this meant
queries which looked
for lat-long data,
had reduced table scans,
resulting in a huge perf
improvement.
Now obviously, using
a space-filling curve
is not the right solution
for every problem,
but it does offer a good
reminder-- to get the best
performance out
of Cloud Bigtable,
it's essential to think
carefully about how
you compose your row key.
If you're interested to know
more about this problem,
check out the article linked
in the description below.
And don't forget to
subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more great Cloud
Performance Atlas content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]